obviously i got a lot of lovely people
in my life and i stay creative
it may be time to re-crown brad as
hollywood's most eligible bachelor six
years after his split from angelina a
new report says brad is dating again no
word on who but a source tells e.t brad
has been very private he has been on
casual dates but none of them have
evolved into anything serious i gotta
add this to my tinder profile
you know usually anyone who stands next
to me usually
it's usually reported as
fueling the rumors well high kicking
brad's been looking super happy and
chill on his press blitz for bullet
train last week he hit the red carpet in
london and it appears brad removed the
stomach tattoo he had showing angie's
birth date
and check out brad's new bachelor pad
the actor spending 40 million dollars on
this spectacular cliffside mansion in
carmel california i have a strict belief
that
architecture has ability to lift your
soul
the stunning craftsman style home is
reportedly about 3 000 square feet and
constructed with granite and sandstone
quarried from the cliffs there it was
built in 1918 the actor has a passion
for historic homes including this frank
lloyd wright house in illinois angelina
arranged a visit for his birthday back
in 2006. you studied architecture this
is your passion really i mean you're my
own on your own it's one of the few art
forms that you can be inside and you can
experience it that's where the levee
broke brad was also of course pivotal in
helping rebuild new orleans after
hurricane katrina this is more about
symbolism and the possibility of what it
can be
again
as for his divorce well things are still
bitter between these exes angelina did
just win a minor victory in the battle
over their french vineyard an la judge
ruling brad must turn over his business
documents to angelina's legal team
[Music]